so a good person comes out in a couple
of days yes March 24th I mean I can't
imagine what went into making it uh just
like emotionally and also just a sheer
hard work it was really it was really
I'm but I'm really proud of it and I
hope people go check it out um it's a
struggle to get people to go to the
theaters these days so here's my my
blatant ask to go check it out in the
theaters um it's it's it's beautifully
shot by an amazing cinematographer and
and um and I really do believe they both
give pretty outstanding performances
yeah they do you know that because you
saw it yeah I do know that and uh and
also if it helps I'm putting a brand new
microwave oven uh still in the box under
one of the seats
this thing retails for like 160 I didn't
say it was a good microwave so when
you're in the theater make sure to look
under your seat yeah just briefly but
don't you keep your eye on the screen
um and how are you right now are you and
now that this process is done
you're in a good place I am in a good
place I'm I'm I have a lot of fun stuff
uh happening um I directed an episode of
Bill's new show shrinking which I'm
which I'm really proud of I think it's a
really good show
um and uh and releasing this movie which
is has been my baby for so long uh it
was it was ready to be released at the
end of last year but um Florence had two
other big movies come out and so we
decided to hold it for the spring
um so you know it's holding something
you're proud of that you want to share
with the world back for so long is now
it's finally coming out so it's really
exciting yeah that's the thing that I
say I can't you know I'm in the we think
of it it's gone but what about the
Simpsons I mean there's oh that was
different you knew you'd written a funny
joke and you had to wait like how long
yes I know I know that was a different
experience but that was so long ago I
mean Simpsons fans will come up to me
and talk to me as if I just finished
working on the episode that I worked on
that they liked and I'll I have to
explain to them because they're so young
that I'm uh you know I think you wrote
it like recently or else they don't
really they just they just think oh so
you know they're quoting lines from
things and I'll think I don't know what
you're talking about uh you know I it's
like telling a whenever a confederate
soldier who's like 98 remember that in
that first battle I'm like no I don't I
don't remember it was so long ago I
should have said Union I know I was
really confused about your choice of a
confederation
can I just say I just like the cap they
had that Cadet cap was a good cap yeah
the union guys had those yeah no they
were blue I like a gray cat Okay a great
a blue cap is too strong it's like the
world where you're going and chatting up
old Confederate soldiers yeah I want to
see that podcast it sounds like a
podcast yeah let's do a much better
guess than me
um but uh they'll talk to me about this
thing but I do remember back then the
time between thinking of the idea for an
episode and seeing it could be a year
more than a year because it was
animation yeah that's what's so crazy
about animation and it's it really is
analogous here because I've had to wait
so long we completed it and we had to
wait so long to finally share it it's
it's made me think of you in animation
like wow we're all so proud of that
episode it's gonna be a year for anyone
to see it you know my life has changed
so much Sona has it yeah let me tell you
how I can just get all this stuff
delivered right to my door I mean you
grew up when I did in the early 1920s
that was unheard of you know a kid in a
cap you had to hey boy boy you know and
you'd have to say yes sir and you'd have
to say you know toss him a coin go get
me that goose in the window he'd say yes
sir Mr Scrooge but it was that was was
like back then yeah but now it's not so
much of our world digitized and
automated why stick to Old School
mailing and shipping if you mail or ship
often let stamps.com do the hard part
for you simply print Postage and
shipping labels right from your home or
office it's ready to go in minutes no
long lines are complicated setup
required it's the easiest so the best
yeah postage rates just increased again
hello luckilystamps.com has the best
discounts in the industry avoid the
hassle and get started with stamps.com
today sign up at steps.com Conan for a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Conan
there's so many people that never and I
see them all the time because I mean
hero we make our podcast in Larchmont
and in La there are all these cafes and
I always see is people working on their
screenplay yeah that's what people came
out here to do is yeah write their
screenplay and I was sitting yesterday
with uh two of the guys I work with uh
Mike and that and they were just I think
there were four people around me working
on screenplays and I think it's just
it's such a gift to get something made
because so many things aren't made
yeah it's important it's the most insane
obstacle course to get anything made
yeah I mean uh it's even with Morgan
Freeman and Florence Pugh uh starring
it's not like um you know everyone's
gonna make it I mean you have to find
the right person who wants to yeah you
also want to make someone you want to
find someone who's going to honor the
vision they're going to let you make it
how you want to make it exactly and not
say we have an idea they're buddy cops
yeah that is yeah not what I wrote yeah
I wrote a story about loss and you know
Crossing generations and how people do
in them nope
there's another there's another great uh
thing I don't know if you've ever
watched uh there was a spoof of the
pilot making process called the TV set
with David Duchovny I think I did see
that
I highly recommend that too you'll love
that um but there's a funny moment in
that where the company plays the
showrunner and it's his idea and they're
they're finally making
this thing and uh Sigourney Weaver plays
the head of the studio and she she comes
to him she goes look we want to talk to
you about the the suicide uh thing with
your brother in the story
and he goes that that's that was the
whole impetus for the script I mean the
reason the reason I wrote this script
was my brother's suicide and and uh that
started the whole story and it's kind of
the whole foundation on upon which this
is built and there's a long pause and
she goes
but what if it wasn't
[Laughter]
well Zach Braff congratulations on a
good person and on a uh an excellent
career and uh and thank you for being so
supportive of me through all the years
you've always been a cheerleader of mine
and I really genuinely appreciate it
well you're I mean since the first time
I saw you I thought this guy's really
funny and you have such a great energy
and spirit and so and I'm glad I'm proud
of what you've I'm proud I always it's
so funny when I'm when I because I'm
older than so many of the people that I
interview and you know including Patrick
Stewart
as they get younger I get older uh no
but um I do when young when super young
people come on my came on my late night
show and I liked them and then they go
on to challenge themselves and do cool
things I always take a little bit of
like oh good for you as if you were my
son well you can you can say that and
you can say proud because I you knew me
right when I was yeah wide-eyed in
beginning and uh and um I'm your
Orthodox father
this is the weirdest version of Star
Wars
what a twist you didn't see that coming
Luke I'm your Orthodox father